[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend hinein das nicht
ganz einfach
auszusprechende wort mit dem doppelten
pf können wir alle erst mal zu den akten
legen die impfpflicht für deutschland
ist gescheitert im parlament damit ist
auch olaf scholz gescheitert mit einem
ganz persönlichen anliegen dass er
bereits ende november als designierter
bundeskanzler hier im heute-journal
vorgetragen hat sie muss zu einem
zeitpunkt kommen wo auch jeder der jetzt
sich entschließt sich impfen zu lassen
und bisher noch nicht geimpft ist zwei
impfungen realistisch bekommen haben
kann deshalb finde ich wäre es richtig
wenn sie für alle gilt ab anfang februar
anfang märz jetzt haben wir anfang april
und der bundeskanzler hat keine eigene
mehrheit im bundestag zusammen bekommen
für einen gesetzentwurf dessen
entstehungsweise bereits mehr als mühsam
war das sollte eine sternstunde des
parlaments werden es wurde
parteitaktisches klein-klein heike
slansky hat mir
es war von anfang an ein pokerspiel
keine eigene mehrheit in der
ampelkoalition deshalb
parteiübergreifende gruppenanträge
getarnt als gewissensentscheidung ohne
fraktionszwang doch der plan ging nicht
auf mit ja haben gestimmt
mit schadenfreude bei der afg
178 die impfpflicht vorerst gescheitert
enttäuschung dagegen beim
gesundheitsminister der eigene
koalitionspartner die fdp fast
geschlossen von der fahne gegangen
schuld jedoch sei die union es ist
schief gegangen dass zunächst einmal die
union sich nicht beteiligt hat an dem
also verfahren der gruppenanträge
sondern als fraktion einen eigenen
antrag gebracht hat er eigentlich nur
eine verschiebung des problems war ist
es nicht richtig hier mit dem finger auf
die unionsfraktion zu zeiten wir haben
eine politische idee und die haben wir
versucht durchzusetzen wenn der
bundeskanzler seine vorstellungen
durchsetzen will dann muss er sich die
mehrheit in seiner koalition suchen das
ist sinn zweck und hintergrund einer
parlamentarischen demokratie
es war eine hitzige debatte argumente
für und wider der impfpflicht union und
fdp fast geschlossen dagegen spd und
grüne mehrheitlich dafür wir haben den
letzten und dem vorletzten corona herbst
verschlafen wir waren nicht ordentlich
vorbereitet und wir haben deswegen auch
die interessen unserer bevölkerung nicht
ausreichend geschützt und das darf uns
einfach nicht noch einmal passieren wenn
wir alle in verantwortung genommen
impfungen gegen den selbstschutz und
nicht im fremdschutz wenn wir uns auch
diese punkte verständigen können darf es
aus verfassungsrechtlichen gründen keine
impfpflicht geben es ist nämlich nicht
die aufgabe des staates erwachsenen
menschen gegen ihren willen zum
selbstschutz zu finden die schärfsten
worte dagegen von der afg ihr eigener
antrag sah vor die bereits gültige
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
zurückzunehmen doch auch das geschichte
der pflicht ist nicht nur radikal
verfassungsfeindlich
sie ist eine totalitäre anmaße eine
entwürdigung des individuums corona
polarisiert die linke bis zuletzt
unentschieden mit nur einem wortbeitrag
präsent gegen die impfpflicht die
deutschen geisterfahrer gegen den rest
der welt wo kein mensch mehr über
endlich nachdenkt und diskutiert das
kann doch nicht ihr ernst sein der
kanzler und sein minister hatten ihr
ganzes politisches gewicht in die
waagschale geworfen
impfen ab 18 war mal das ziel auf den
letzten metern modifiziert und trotzdem
verloren eine politische niederlage und
kein fahrplan aus der pandemie
till steffen ist der parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der grünen war
eigentlich für die impfpflicht ab 18 hat
dann den jetzt gescheiterten
kompromissentwurf impfpflicht ab 60
maßgeblich mitverhandelt guten abend
herr steffen und name sie was ja die
strategie war ohne fraktionszwang
abzustimmen dabei war eigentlich damals
schon klar das wird nicht einfach mit
einer eigenen mehrheit für die ampel
jetzt haben sie es nicht geschafft zu
überzeugen was ist schiefgelaufen
ja es war natürlich klar wenn ein
regierungsentwurf nicht vorliegt dann
ist es kein einfacher weg als
abgeordnete freuen wir uns natürlich
auch immer wenn die regierung entwurf
vorliegt aber wenn das nicht der fall
ist bei so einer wichtigen frage dann
ist es unsere aufgabe eigene
gesetzesvorschläge vorzulegen das haben
die gemacht den haben wir uns gestellt
haben ein gesetzentwurf vorgelegt für
die einführung einer impfpflicht und
cdu/csu und fdp die sind heute ihrer
verantwortung für die gesundheit unseres
landes nicht gerecht geworden jetzt
haben sie gesagt die regierung hätte
eigentlich einen gesetzentwurf vorlegen
müssen das heißt olaf scholz hat
handwerkliche fehler gemacht es ist
immer schön wenn die regierung wenn wir
für vorlegt aber es gibt natürlich auch
die möglichkeit dass aus dem parlament
aus der mitte des parlaments heraus
gesetzentwürfe vorgelegt werden die sind
natürlich gleichwertig und am ende haben
die abgeordneten die verantwortung zu
dem gesetzentwurf ja oder nein zu sagen
und heute haben wir gesehen eine
mehrheit im haus war nicht bereit diese
verantwortung für unser land zu
übernehmen gut dass jetzt die opposition
einen eigenen politischen erfolg
erringen möchte kann man hier vielleicht
gar nicht verübeln was sagen sie denn
zur fdp die ja auch quasi geschlossen
von der fahne gegangen ist ihnen von der
fahne gegangen ist ich glaube dass es in
der tat eine situation wo wir jetzt vor
der situation stehen dass landtagswahlen
anstehen und die fdp offenbar hier sich
gefragt hat mit welchem profil wollen
wenn die landtagswahlen gehen das ist
natürlich dann nicht hilfreich wenn man
eine solche sachfrage sinnvoll
beantworten möchte und gleichzeitig hat
die union ja gegen ihre inhaltliche
überzeugung dass wir die fdp immerhin
zugutehalten dass sie einmal gesagt
haben sie sind da kritisch aufgestellt
die union hat aber immer gesagt wir
möchten so eine impfpflicht hendrik wüst
ministerpräsident nordrhein westfalen
hat das noch kürzlich eingefordert und
die eigene bundestagsfraktion hat dann
heute gegen den konkreten gesetzentwurf
gestimmt der eine solche impfung wird
hätte das ist tatsächlich inhaltlich sie
zufrieden gut gegen ihren gesetzentwurf
hc gestimmt reden wir nochmal über
diesen gesetzentwurf der war ja ein
blick nach st also die union hat ja in
folge licht im herbst ein flickenteppich
den sie vorgelegt haben im herbst nur
auf 60 dann im september noch einmal
überprüfen ob er überhaupt nötig ist und
die kriterien bei der ganzen sache
unklar da sind sie ja nicht mit dem
allerbesten werk in die abstimmung
gegangen es gibt diesen alten spruch in
gefahr und größter not bringt der
mittelweg den tod nein politik ist kunst
des möglichen und natürlich muss es
manchmal kompromisse geben wir haben
gesehen es gibt unterschiedliche
initiativen die wollen die gleiche
richtung und haben uns dann
zusammengesetzt wie können wir
tatsächlich hier zu einer gemeinsamen
linie kommen und die impfpflicht für
alle menschen ab 60 ist natürlich die
impfpflicht für diejenigen von denen das
größte potenzial ausgeht dass sie dann
schwere verläufe haben und dann
natürlich zu einer überlastung des
gesundheitswesens führen können eine
impfpflicht mit einer vollständigen
impfung aller über 60-jährigen ab erster
oktober das hätte uns natürlich schon
eine ganze menge vorangebracht
hätte sagen sie jetzt herr steffen wir
müssen über das timing des ganzen reden
gerade im moment gehen die zahlen ja
deutlich runter die infektionszahlen wir
sehen wie überall auch in deutschland
die maßnahmen auslaufen
die koalition hat sich mit all dem jahr
sehr sehr viel zeit gelassen und am ende
wirkte die impfpflicht irgendwie nicht
mehr wichtig auch wenn man sieht was
sonst alles in der welt passiert ja wir
wissen ja ganz klar wir kriegen im
herbst wieder eine welle wir wissen
nicht mit welcher variante deswegen
wissen wir noch nicht ganz wie
schwerwiegend diese welle werden wird
aber es war immer klar wir reden bei
dieser in pflicht über die drei
impfungen die wir im herbst brauchen wir
reden also niemals über den jetzigen
zeitpunkt ist es gut dass jetzt mehr
freiheiten möglich sind aber wir wissen
wie wir dass erhalten wollen dann
brauchen wir eine höhere impfquote im
herbst und dafür sollte die impfpflicht
dienen kann der gesundheitsminister der
ja mit seinem kernprojekt heute auch
gescheitert ist weitermachen wie bisher
wir brauchen natürlich jetzt nur so
zusammensetzen als koalitionen müssen
jetzt einen schlüssigen plan auf den
tisch legen und wie wir jetzt mit der
korona politik weitermachen mit dem
absinken der inzidenz wie sie erwähnt
haben ist es nicht vorbei dass wir uns
im koma man müssen sondern wir brauchen
jetzt und ich denke die ereignisse der
letzten tage machen das auch sehr
deutlich wir brauchen jetzt einen
schlüssigen ansatz für die weitere
kroner politik und nach meiner
überzeugung müssen wir uns vorbehalten
auch wieder zu impfpflicht
zurückzukehren ganz ganz kurz nachher
steffen bitte impfpflicht im herbst wird
die noch irgendwie kommen oder ist jetzt
komplett durch wir müssen uns das
vorbehalten ist wäre was herzlich
vorbehalten sie sind ja jetzt gerade
gescheitert mit dem neuen aber klar wenn
wir alle haben ja gesagt wir brauchen
natürlich dieses mittel werden wir
schwerere verläufe haben das haben wir
auch viele derjenigen gesagt die heute
mit nein gestimmt haben und darauf
werden wir natürlich zurück kommen aber
aus meiner perspektive ist auch klar
wenn wir dazu zurückkehren dann nur auf
basis eines entwurfs der bundesregierung
sagte steffen parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der grünen im zdf heute
journal herzlichen dank herr steffen
da war schon weg aber wir machen jetzt
hier weiter die impfpflicht und was aus
ihr wurde dazu jetzt der kommentar hier
von susanne biedenkopf
es hat etwas vom letzten akt eines
trauerspiels nach abenteuerlichen
kehrtwenden verschlimmbessert
gesetzesentwürfen erregten debatten eine
vergeigte abstimmung aus und vorbei das
war es erstmal mit der impfpflicht eine
blamage für das hohe haus zu einfach
denn es ist kompliziert das virus hat
sich schneller verändert als der
politische diskurs inzidenz die noch im
letzten sommer unvorstellbar waren
leichte symptome einer omikron variante
vor allem aber viele fragezeichen für
die zukunft der pandemie und keine
überzeugende blaupause für die
impfpflicht in wirren zeiten verlaufen
auch entscheidungsprozesse nicht so
geradlinig wie die schienen einer
eisenbahn da müssen wege gesucht
getestet geändert werden oder geht auch
mal was richtig schief vielleicht müssen
wir das scheitern eines gesetzesentwurfs
einfach aushalten es könnte schlimmer
sein ich freue mich gerade in diesen
zeiten das in unserem parlament
gestritten wird frei von fraktionszwang
das vorlagen abgeschmettert werden und
nicht mit halber überzeugung abzunicken
sind dass unsere demokratie in sich die
chance der verbesserung birgt verbessern
aber kann sich nur wer niederlagen er
kennt und daraus lernen will am besten
kommt die einsicht vor der nächsten
abstimmung und setzen wir wenn vater
staat es nicht so einfach richten kann
auf das prinzip eigenverantwortung
denn ohne die hilft auch die schönste
freiheit nichts
susanne biedenkopf kommentierte und
hanna macht jetzt hier weiter mit
schlimmen nachrichten die heute abend
aus israel kommen bei einem anschlag im
zentrum von tel aviv sind mindestens
zwei menschen getötet worden mehrere
weitere personen wurden verletzt
laut der polizei fielen die schüsse in
einer beliebten gegend der stadt mit
zahlreichen cafés und bars die
sicherheitskräfte forderten die menschen
auf in ihren wohnungen zu bleiben die
hintergründe der tat sind noch unklar in
den vergangenen zwei wochen waren in
israel bei einer anschlagsserie elf
menschen getötet worden
der us-senat hat vor wenigen stunden
kita braun jackson als neue
verfassungsrichterin am us supreme court
bestätigt jackson wird damit die erste
schwarze richterin am obersten gericht
in der geschichte der usa das votum galt
trotz der nur knappen demokratischen
mehrheit im oberhaus als sicher da auch
drei der kubanische senatoren ihre
zustimmung angekündigt hatten
jemens präsident hadi hat überraschend
seine macht an einen neu gegründeten
präsidialrat abgetreten das neue gremium
soll das land übergangsweise führen und
außerdem mit den houthi rebellen über
eine lösung des jahrelangen konflikts
verhandeln seit 2005 10 tobt im jemen
ein stellvertreterkrieg mit
hunderttausenden toten dabei
unterstützen saudiarabien und andere
golfstaaten die jemenitische regierung
und iran die houthi rebellen erst am
samstag hat eine zweimonatige waffenruhe
begonnen
ein türkisches gericht hat den prozess
um die ermordung des saudi-arabischen
bloggers sascha gestoppt stattdessen
soll das verfahren nun in saudi arabien
stattfinden menschenrechtler kritisieren
dass mit dieser entscheidung die letzte
hoffnung auf gerechtigkeit verstreichen
würde
2018 wacker schott ii im saudischen
konsulat in istanbul von einem
spezialkommando aus saudi arabien
getötet worden
rund fünf wochen vor der landtagswahl in
nordrhein westfalen ist
cdu-umweltministerin hsh zurückgetreten
hintergrund ist eine mallorca-reise der
umweltministerin kurz nach der
flutkatastrophe im vergangenen juli
heute war bekannt geworden dass sie dort
gemeinsam mit kabinettskollegen den
geburtstag ihres mannes feierte zuvor
hatte rainer esser noch angegeben
lediglich ihre tochter abgeholt zu haben
die opposition hatte die ministerin
heute zu dem rücktritt aufgefordert in
nordrhein westfalen haben 49 menschen
durch die flut ihr leben verloren
die eu staaten haben ein weiteres
sanktionspaket gegen russland auf den
weg gebracht darin enthalten ist auch
ein importstopp für russische kohle nun
ist außerdem klar dass es eine
viermonatige übergangs christa vergeben
wird das hatte unter anderem deutschland
gefordert weiterer teil des
sanktionspaket ist ein vollständiges
transaktions verbot zu lasten viel
wichtiger russischer banken und
russische schiffe sowie von russland
betriebene schiffe dürfen nicht mehr in
eu häfen einlaufen
die un-vollversammlung hat die
mitgliedschaft russlands im
menschenrechtsrat ausgesetzt damit
reagierten die vereinten nationen auf
berichte über russische menschenrechts
verletzungen in der ukraine russland
verliert damit alle rechte seiner
mitgliedschaft und darf nicht mehr an
den sitzungen teilnehmen 24 mitglieder
stimmten gegen die suspendierung
darunter auch china
was passiert wenn das eine wichtig ist
und das andere auch aber eine bundes
außenministerin sich nun mal nicht
zweiteilen kann war heute am terminplan
von annalena baerbock zu sehen sie war
schon in brüssel beim nato-treffen wegen
des ukraine krieges und musste dann
zurück nach berlin wegen der impfpflicht
abstimmung ihre stimme hat die
niederlage für die impf politik der
regierung nicht verhindern können
darüber haben wir ja schon berichtet und
auch in brüssel bahnt sich etwas an was
bei der bundesregierung durchaus
stirnrunzeln verursachen dürfte
wahrscheinlicher sind kopfschmerzen die
ukraine fordert kriegswaffen speziell
von deutschland insgesamt plant die nato
eine deutliche ausweitung der
militärischen unterstützung
ein radikaler kurswechsel wie florian
neumann berichtet es ist halb zehn
morgens an diesem donnerstag und die
deutsche außenministerin hat erstmal
keine zeit mehr für die nato der kanzler
hat gebeten zurück zu reisen nach berlin
zur abstimmung über die impfpflicht
wenigstens an ihr soll es nicht
scheitern
wer hat zeit und wie viel das ist eine
der fragen die der nato tagung und der
eingeladene außenminister aus der
ukraine beklagt dass manche sich zu viel
zeit lassen er meint deutschland
was mich am meisten besorgt ist wie
lange entscheidungsprozesse in berlin
dauern denn während berlin zeit hat hat
kiew das nicht mehr am 42 tag des
krieges in seiner heimat wird die
metropole bei der nato in brüssel erst
mal geherzt von beinahe jedem was er
aber will sind waffen so schnell so
viele wie möglich stärkere als bisher
noch auf dem nato gipfel vor zwei wochen
hatten sie eigentlich verabredet keine
kampfpanzer in die ukraine zu liefern zu
groß die sorge dadurch in diesen krieg
gezogen zu werden doch die bilder der
kriegsverbrechen der zerstörung heute
etwa aus borodjanka 60 kilometer von
kiew entfernt lassen die nato
verbündeten ihren kurs ändern
die klare botschaft des heutigen
treffens ist dass die alliierten mehr
tun sollen und bereit sind mehr zu tun
um die ukraine auszustatten wir sind uns
der dringlichkeit bewusst
wir gucken tagtäglich was sie unserer
meinung nach am meisten benötigen
einschließlich neuer waffensysteme die
sie bisher nicht bekommen haben ein
verwalter öffentlicher nennt niemand
details aber es geht um panzer wie
tschechien sie bereits geliefert hat
folgen andere gar deutschland die
ukraine hätte gern panzer vom typ marder
ausgemustert von der bundeswehr unklar
ob sie schnell einsatztauglich gemacht
werden könnten die aussenministerin sagt
weder ja noch nein wir stehen
solidarisch an der seite der ukraine
deswegen schauen wir uns auch gemeinsam
all das an was es zu einer besseren
verteidigung in zukunft der ukraine
brauchen könnte während berlin noch
überlegt öffnet sich anderswo ein
zeitfenster für eine möglicherweise
historische umwälzungen schweden und
finnland sind wie immer bei diesen
treffen zu gast bei der nato und bald
mittendrin beide länder historisch
neutral in der eu aber nicht in der nato
doch unter dem eindruck des krieges in
der nachbar russland führt ändert sich
die stimmung radikal allerdings
ihre militärische angriff zeigt doch was
russland in der lage ist zu mobilisieren
und das ändert die einschätzung der
sicherheitslage in vielen europäischen
staaten auch in finnland
sollten beide länder wollen die bekämen
was die ukraine jahrelang herbeisehnte
im eiltempo die aufnahme in die nato ein
wunsch den die ukraine aufgegeben hat
als der außenminister am nachmittag
abreist hat er stattdessen seine waffen
wunschliste hinterlassen und die
botschaft dass ihnen daheim die zeit
davonrennt
in moskau spricht der kreml heute von
einer gewaltigen tragödie und meint
damit nicht den eigenen angriffskrieg
gegen die ukraine all die toten und
vermissten dort sondern die russischen
soldaten die umgekommen sind der satz
des sprechers von präsident putin ist
dennoch bemerkenswert weil es ihnen so
bislang nicht gegeben hat wir haben
bedeutende verluste sagt dimitri peskow
christian senn ist unserer
moskau-korrespondent genommen christian
ist das jetzt ein wendepunkt in der
staatspropaganda oder kommt man einfach
auch im kreml nicht mehr an der tatsache
vorbei dass immer mehr soldaten tot nach
hause kommen
ich würde sagen es ist tatsächlich
beides wenn man die beiden sachen jetzt
so zusammenfasst ist einerseits
natürlich sehr bemerkenswert dass paskov
diese aus sage so öffentlich trifft denn
man darf nicht vergessen dass das reden
über die toten zahlen über die opfer in
einem krieg dass das hier als
staatsgeheimnis gilt und wenn jetzt
gesagt dass es viele sind verbietet sich
jetzt eigentlich über die zahlen zu
diskutieren wir können die bandbreite ja
noch mal kurz beschreiben die ukraine
spricht von rund 19.000 die letzte
offizielle russische zahl war über 1300
also wir können davon ausgehen dass es
viele sind wie viele
wissen wir nicht und dazu kann man nicht
sagen andererseits zeitgleich laufen im
russischen staatsfernsehen
auch bilder auf denen angeblich
russische soldaten gezeigt werden die
brutal getötet werden angeblich von
ukrainern also man will mit dieser
aussage auch gleichzeitig glaube ich
auch zeigen wer dafür verantwortlich ist
christian seinem herzlichen dank für
diese einschätzung live aus moskau und
gleichzeitig bangen sie in der ukraine
vor dem was russland als nächstes plant
eine großoffensive im osten könnte
bevorstehen und weiteres leid bringen
auch und gerade für die die nicht
verstehen was da passiert in ihrer welt
die mit kinderaugen mehr horror gesehen
haben als selbst erwachsene ertragen
könnten jörg brase berichtet
schattenkrieger heißt das spiel das mich
ja manchmal auf dem handy spielt micha
ist sechs jahre alt vor einem monat kam
er aus rache für im osten der ukraine
dort erlebte er den echten krieg
ich bin mit meiner mutter meiner
schwester meiner tante und meinem cousin
bekommen sagte
tagelang hockte micha interaktiv mit
seiner familie im luftschutzkeller
bombardierungen und flucht haben bei dem
sechsjährigen ihre spuren hinterlassen
die explosionen waren schrecklich der
junge bekam große angst und er hat
nachts nicht mehr geschlafen er hat oft
geschrien und begann zu stottern
außerdem hatte er nervöses augenzucken
hier in lemberg ist der krieg noch weit
weg psychologen kümmern sich um
traumatisierte kinder wie micha in dem
ehemaligen kurhotel am stadtrand von
lemberg sind 90 flüchtlinge
untergekommen mütter mit ihren kindern
psychologin irina bietet für die älteren
gesprächsgruppen an sie ist selbst
flüchtling aus lugansk versucht den
jugendlichen mit der verarbeitung der
eigenen kriegserfahrung zu helfen
wenn ich die sirenen höhere sage ich mir
als erstes das zu meinem schutz ist dass
die sirene keine gefahr bedeutet dass
sie mir hilft mein leben zu retten
außerdem mache ich keine langfristigen
pläne mehr so wie früher sondern nur
noch kurzfristige für heute für die
nächste woche den nächsten monat
für die kleinen gibt es mal therapie wir
fragen sie nach ihren erlebnissen sagt
die psychologin um sie nicht noch mal zu
traumatisieren wenn sie etwas wissen
wollen antworten wir ehrlich kyrill floh
mit seinen eltern aus kiew sein vater
brachte sie in sicherheit ging dann
zurück um die hauptstadt zu verteidigen
das machte ihm angst sagt kyritz mutter
die draußen vor der tür wartet
danach kam ein sohn und fragte mich wird
papa getötet ich sagte ihm ich weiß es
nicht alles kann passieren
kyrill ist schon sechs jahre alt aber
danach begann er ein zu messen und das
tut er wie ein baby tagsüber und in der
nacht
nach den ersten sitzungen geht es schon
etwas besser die kinder malen sich ihre
ängste von der seele sie spüren die
anspannung auch die angst der eltern wie
möhren er kommt aus der gegend von
lemberg hat nie selbst angriffe gesehen
oder gehört und doch malt er wie die
panzer kommen
um die menschen die aus der ukraine nach
deutschland geflüchtet sind geht es
jetzt gerade im moment im kanzleramt
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
das sind natürlich viele einzelne
schicksale und dennoch hört sich die
tagesordnung der bund länder gespräche
sehr juristisch bürokratisch an denn
hinter all den fragen unterbringung
gesundheitsversorgung schule jobs steht
eine große frage nämlich wer bezahlt
theo guten abend das hieß immer das ist
eine große gemeinschaftsaufgabe heißt es
dass immer noch
ja da sind sich alle bund und länder
weiterhin eigentlich die aufnahme der
ukrainischen flüchtlinge steht völlig
außer frage weniger weit offen als das
herz allerdings ist das portemonnaie bei
vielen beteiligten und auch das ist ja
kein unvertraut das phänomen wobei es
angesichts der aktuell ja extrem
angespannten haushaltslagen nochmals
verstärkt zu sein scheint es ist
verbunden mit der großen alles auch
unkalkulierbar machenden frage wie viele
flüchtlinge kommen noch zusätzlich
insbesondere wenn der krieg immer
grausamer wird und geht es dabei um
monate oder geht es um jahre was ja
angesichts der dramatischen zerstörung
auch nicht unrealistisch ist bisher sind
die länder in vorleistung gegangen und
wollen jetzt nicht nur dass der bund
ihnen für die zurückliegenden monate
eine pauschale bezahlt sondern dass er
sich auch sehr deutlich an den künftigen
kosten beteiligt der bund wiederum hat
schon zwei riesige schattenhaushalte am
bein und will den ländern keine
blankoschecks ausstellen ich höre das
aktuell im kanzleramt im kleinen kreis
ein kompromiss ausgelotet werde aber die
politische macht ist ja noch jung ist
dann irgendwie absehbar theo wie dieser
kompromiss dann aussehen könnte und was
ja auch eine wichtige frage ist wäre das
dann eine sonderlösung quasi also nur
für ukraine flüchtlinge oder gilt die
dann für alle anderen auch
interessante der frage liegt im grunde
genau eines der probleme wenn die
ukrainischen kriegsflüchtlinge wie von
den ländern jetzt gefordert
grundsicherung bekommen also die
gleichen leistungen wie etwa hartz 4
empfänger dann würden sie sich von
anderen läufern vielen anderen
flüchtlingen unterscheiden sondern
bekämen die ukraine höhere leistungen
eine bessere gesundheitsversorgung und
eine frühere unterstützung beim in den
arbeitsmarkt all das ist jedem zu
wünschen hieße aber in der tat eine
besserstellung zu anderen auch das gilt
ist da heute abend im kanzleramt zu
bedenken also wird spannend wird
möglicherweise auch ungemütlich sowie
das wetter hinter dir theo herzlichen
dank für diese einordnung heute abend
und wir bleiben beim geld noch mal
hammer langsam aber sicher wird es immer
spürbarer das leben wird teurer die
inflation in der eu hat gerade erst mein
rekord erreicht damit steigt mehr und
mehr auch der druck auf die notenbanken
oder könnte es bald bewegung geben
zumindest stefanie bareth mehren sich im
rat der europäischen zentralbank die
stimmen für eine zinswende
ja es scheint tatsächlich die zeit reif
für eine zinswende in der eu nicht
sofort aber wahrscheinlich im spätsommer
das geht aus den jüngsten protokollen
der ezb sitzung hervor die heute in
frankfurt bekannt wurden darin heißt es
eine hohe anzahl von mitgliedern sei für
sofortige schritte zur normalisierung
der geldpolitik um die anhaltend hohe
inflation einzudämmen ob die ezb
allerdings die inflation tatsächlich
noch einfangen kann ist umstritten denn
die preise werden aktuell vom knappen
angebot getrieben und wir werden vorerst
weder mehr nägel noch holz bekommen nur
weil die zinsen steigen zudem verschärft
der ukraine krieg die energie- und
lebensmittelpreise aber dennoch es wäre
ein wichtiges signal denn der leitzins
liegt aktuell auf dem rekordtief von 0
prozent der einlagenzins den banken bei
der ezb zahlen müssen sogar bei minus
0,5 prozent vielen sparern wäre schon
geholfen wenn dieser strafzins wegfiele
den kritikern reagiert die ezb zu
zögerlich denn die usa die gehen wie
gestern bekannt wurde in diesem jahr mit
mehreren entschlossenen schritten voran
ende des jahres könnte der us-leitzins
sogar in einer spanne von über
zweieinhalb prozent liegen in den
staaten ist der inflationsdruck
allerdings auch sehr viel größer deshalb
ist anzunehmen dass die ezb ihr eine
langsamere gangart an den tag legt eine
stabile erholung ist hier am aktienmarkt
hier nicht in sicht krieg und drohende
stagnation machen es dem dax weiterhin
schwer danke stefanie nach frankfurt
ein ergebnis vom fußball im
viertelfinal-hinspiel der europa league
haben sich rb leipzig und der
italienische erstligist atalanta bergamo
unentschieden getrennt mit eins zu eins
und es gibt eine amtliche
unwetterwarnung der deutsche
wetterdienst warnt aktuell vor orkanböen
und orkanartigen böen in höheren lagen
der südhälfte deutschlands
eine aufnahme der kanadischen fotografen
m becken ist zum pressefoto des jahres
gekürt worden das bild erinnert an 215
indigene kinder deren gebeine letztes
jahr in kanada auf dem ehemaligen
gelände einer katholischen
internatsschule entdeckt wurden der fund
des massengrabs nahe der stadt kamloops
hatte das land zutiefst erschüttert
jahrzehntelang waren kinder von
ureinwohnern zwangsweise in internate
gesteckt worden um sie dort umzuerziehen
und das war unsere welt an diesem
donnerstag gleich nach uns hier im zdf
jetzt werte waffen wirtschaftskraft mit
aller macht gegen putin eine sehr
spannende runde bei der kollegin maybrit
illner wir wünschen ihnen jetzt noch
einen angenehmen abend tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die kaltfront die
uns heute überquert hat mit schauern
gewittern und sturm bis ins flachland
schmiegt sich allmählich an die alpen an
ja und das nächste tief wartet schon
draußen auf dem atlantik kommt von der
biscaya mit der feuchtigkeit bringt
regen schnee und viel wind mit und den
schauen wir uns genau an im norden
deutschlands gibt es geschwindigkeiten
bis 80 kilometer pro stunde in der mitte
wird es allmählich weniger bei 65
kilometer pro stunde und mit dem neuen
tief 100 kilometer pro stunde im
tagesverlauf das verlagert sich langsam
nach osten in der nacht liegt die
kaltfront im süden oder regnet es in der
mitte regnet es ebenfalls in den höheren
lagen fällt schnee bei tiefsten
temperaturen von zwei grad im hessischen
bergland und 9 grad im südwesten
deutschlands
morgen kommt das tief von westen und
erwischt hauptsächlich die südhälfte
deutschlands und dann auf der westseite
der mittelgebirge teils kräftiger regen
teils dauerregen dazu gewitter und
schauer zum abend dann in der mitte auch
schneefall in den mittelgebirgen und
auch im westen das kann durchaus markant
sein nach norden hin gibt es
sonnenschein und das bei höchsten
temperaturen von fünf grad richtung
eifel und 14 grad im südwesten
deutschlands oder auch im süden bleibt
es relativ mild in den nächsten tagen
wird es ziemlich durchwachsen seien vor
allem am samstag noch mit schauern und
gewittern und sturm bei vier bis elf
grad am sonntag wird es allmählich
weniger und schwitzens montag ist es
wärmer und sonniger damit eine schöne
art